so there's a lot of trends in the
Silicon Valley should I as an
entrepreneur look for an idea around the
trend again I think it depends there's a
lot of people who can be very kind of
like French centric you know social
mobile local it's hard so let's all go
chase that or everybody wants to I mean
I don't know how many companies have
heard about shared economy you know back
in 2000 there was a wave about pets so I
think that there's a lot of this it use
the word herd mentality everybody wants
to go do the same thing but having said
that I think it's valuable to look at
current disruptions current dislocations
like for example mobile having ammo
having a camera on the mobile phone or
having your location on the mobile phone
you know it's created businesses around
like uber or Instagram and these are
really mobile first companies and this
wasn't possible six seven eight years
ago so I think studying you know hey
there is this big movement from
landlines to mobile I think people can
consciously think about downstream
impacts of those things and businesses
and can be created music is another
great example you know music has been
massively disrupted you know around how
do you produce it how do you distribute
it and out of that have come companies
like Spotify or even device makers you
know iPods and phones and so on so I
think there's a lot of benefit in
thinking about disruptions and what does
that mean three years from now six years
from now a cloud is a great example all
right II W I started doing cloud and now
there are numerous companies that got
created around that trend security
payments and so on so I think it's
valuable but having said that I don't
want to just recommend that as an only
approach you know we can see companies
that are created in retail in
agriculture in insurance in data and so
on so just old-fashioned industries that
people are not looking at but these are
of opportunity because you know
incumbents populate those and it's not
the sexy thing to do but you can
definitely create businesses there so as
an entrepreneur how should I think about
competition and how should it impact my
product I think it's very important to
be aware of the competition but I think
it also depends on the stage of the
company I have seen entrepreneurs who
get very distracted by trying to follow
and copy every move of their competition
and I think it's not very healthy
especially if you're trying to go after
a new market if you're creating a new
category you let somebody else define
your moves and your product and that's
not healthy but I think as you start
maturing and as you start optimizing
it's useful to think about you know even
small differences in the product can
create massive differences in the
mindset of consumers so I think if I
were to simplify if you're just getting
going if you're a new category don't let
the customer define don't let the
competition define you but if you are
mature I think you need to pay more
attention to the competition